one
and you're live chairman thank you very
much uh good evening and welcome to this
south
east area planning committee meeting on
wednesday
20th of january 20 21 let's get the
century right
uh my name is councillor nick skeens and
i'm the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the fourth of april
in response to the covered 19 situation
and they're just a few household
housekeeping issues to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in this meeting
to ensure your camera remains on where
broadband permits and your microphone
remains muted
when not addressing the committee this
will reduce
background noises and avoid any
unintentional disturbances
this meeting will be hosted remotely via
conferencing software
this allows members of the public to
virtually attend the meeting
whilst being able to protect themselves
and others and observe
the government's lockdown measures we
are streaming this
meeting live as well as recording and by
being present in the meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
points of order or indicating that you
have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions
or any other purpose when
speaking and referring to agenda papers
please ensure
you reference a page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on
the microphone now if i may ask
officers taking part in the meeting to
introduce themselves
starting with mr lee
good evening members i am matthew lee
lead specialist place and chief planning
officer at morden district council thank
you
michael johnson he remembers
michael johnson lead specialist
development management
thank you hannah dungate
good evening members hannah dungate
planning specialist from
development management thank you derek
lawrence
good evening members my name is derrick
lance i'm the
interim senior specialist coordinator
for development management
uh berna casey thank you good evening
members
bernie casey clark to this evening's
committee thank you very much
are there any other officers present
uh that sounds like a no so before i
call on the clerk to make
the roll call of committee members can i
ask
those counselors in attendance to
introduce themselves please
good evening everyone chrissy morris uh
in tonight thank you
anybody else take that as a no
burner can you please now carry out a
roll call of members to confirm who is
in
attendance thank you yes jan
thank you members i will call your names
in alphabetical order
starting with councillor bassinger
you're muted i'm usually of course i am
good evening burner i'm present thank
you
thank you cancer beal
good evening everyone thank you
councillor bell
good evening everyone present councillor
boyce
here thank you councillor chana
um yes i'm here thank you bernard good
evening everyone
thank you cancer helm
present good evening everybody thank you
councillor hull present
good evening everybody that's the
schemes yes i'm here
hi thank you council stamp yeah good
evening bernard members
um officers i'm here thank you very much
thank you chairman
thank you very much yes members please
be advised that we have one
public participant uh in this meeting
this evening
and i will call on them to speak at the
uh appropriate time
uh and now uh item two and apologies for
absence may i have the apologies
for absence please bernard uh thank you
chairman we've received apologies for
absence from counseling dueck
thank you thank you very much okay uh
item
three minutes from the 28th of october
2020
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 28th of october
2020
found on pages 7 to 12 are approved
as a true and accurate record i so
move uh if you wish to second that
motion please turn on your
video and um mute your microphone and
state your name now please
anybody going
thank you councillor helm if any member
wishes to raise any matter of accuracy
please use the hands up function to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
bernard have you seen any other member
indicating a wish to speak
you're muted burner apologies chairman
nobody is indicated with the wish to
speak
uh okay thank you very much uh berna
will we'll now
take the votes taking each member in
alphabetical order please state full
against or abstain or uh do or do you
wish to approve by a saint percent are
you happy to
approve this by ascend
okay what's thank you that said
uh approved
okay so number four is uh declarations
of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable peculiary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members members
are reminded that they are also required
to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise
throughout the meeting if any member has
an interest to declare please
use the hands up function now to
indicate
and i will invite you to speak
chairman with cancer channel please go
ahead council channel
uh thank you chairman uh my normal
declaration
i must declare non-pecuniary interest as
i'm also a member of essex county
council
which is consulted on planning
applications regarding issues that are
in their remit
such as highways access education
and a number of other matters chairman
so anything that they'd be consulted on
and respond to should they choose to i
declare the non-pecuniary interest
thank you very much councillor chana is
there anybody else who would like to
declare
i can't see any hands is there anything
no
thank you okay so we move on to item
five that
twenty strokes zero zero nine
zero two stroke ful
wayside main road london essex cm nine
six
nine u uh we move uh this is the
application i've just described in a
moment
uh it's found on pages 13-24
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known by using the hands up function
within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn and
please keep your points clear and
succinct
uh mr dungate could you please present
the report
with me uh just before you start
somebody has an
unm microphone which is giving us some
background noise
thank you i think that's off now go
ahead thank you
planning permission is sought for the
replacement of four existing
outbuildings
and the erection of new fencing and
gates to the property entrance
at wayside which is shown in red on the
adjacent site plan
this is the location plan for the site
these are the existing and proposed site
plans as well as the proposed elevations
for the gate and fence
it should be noted that an objection was
initially raised in relation to the
distance
of the proposed gate from the public
highway this was amended
during the course of the application and
is now proposed to be cited six metres
back from the main road
in compliance with the highway
authority's recommendation
these are the existing and proposed site
plans for the replacement outbuildings
as you can see the proposal results in
an overall reduction
in the built form at the site
these are the existing floor elevation
and roof plans
for outbuilding c
these are the proposed floor elevation
and roof plans for outbuilding c
these are the existing floor elevation
and roof plans for our building d
and these are the proposed floor
elevation and roof plans for our
building d
these are the existing floor elevation
and roof plans for outbuilding e
and these are the proposed floor
elevation and roof plans for outbuilding
e
these are the existing floor elevation
and roof plans for outbuilding f
and these are proposed for elevation and
roof plans for outbuilding f
these are the floor and elevation plans
for out building b
um and it is proposed for outbuilding b
to partially infill the open sides of
this existing building
but its scale would not be altered as
part of the proposal
these are the existing outbuildings at
the site
and these are the photographs of the
property entrance
at present so to summarize
the proposed development is considered
to have an acceptable
visual impact on the site and
surrounding area
the proposed post and rail fence and
field gate are considered to respect the
rural area and the proposed replacement
outbuildings
would tidy up the existing equestrian
site and results in an overall reduction
in the built form at the site
in addition the proposal would not
detrimentally impact the residential
amenity of the neighbouring occupiers
i would not impact the provision of
private amenity space or parking at
wayside
therefore the proposal is recommended
for approval
thank you chairman thank you very much
uh indeed hannah
now um any other officers need to
comment on this or would like to comment
on
this at all okay
okay sorry right then the recommendation
is set out within the report is as
follows
that planning application 220.00902
stroke full
wayside main road in london be approved
subject to conditions as detailed in
section 8 of the report
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
video i think you've already done that
anyway but unmute your microphone
and state your name now counselor
thank you councillor helm i'll now
invite members to make any comments uh
on the report uh berna has anybody
indicated if they wish to speak
yes chairman councillor chana councillor
china please
go ahead thank you very much chairman
i'm just interested regarding the fence
and the gate at the excess that's
already existing and the requirement
because it was initially obviously going
to be closer to the highway
than six meters what height of gate are
we talking about because there's
obviously it must be that which is
outside permitted development then
i wasn't clear from the report of the
height of the um proposed fence
or or the kite of the gate
i can answer that chairman please go
ahead yeah um
the fence is 1.2 meters in height and
the gates are 1.6 meters in height so
permitted development anything above one
meter in height would require planning
permission
adjacent to a highway and is this a is
that an absolute requirement from the
highways authority to go
six meters back yes it's to stop
any um car or vehicle entering the site
overhanging the highway as they turn
into the site so it's it
is always a requirement whenever i have
come across it that they request
that the gates are pushed back within
the site by six meters
as that's the i guess the general um
depth or measurement of the car or
vehicle so it doesn't overhang the
highway
okay i i suppose i don't see so much
difference between an open gate and an
open entrance
um you could have the same difference i
guess um i suppose they're
thinking of a gate shot that's why just
make that inquiry
because the entrance is there if a car's
coming in
um it must only be in terms of gates
closed but if you're wanting to turn in
i would imagine the gate will be open
it's just i asked that
and regarding the permitted developments
thank you
yes i mean i think the point is is that
the gates are likely to be closed uh
as often as they're open and you don't
want that situation when a car turning
in
has its rear end as it were sticking out
in the traffic
and that also i guess makes it a bit
safer if a number of cars are
coming out onto the highway i don't
person uh first of all is there anybody
else who'd like to speak on this
uh councillor stamp i think is next is
that correct uh yeah
not on this so much uh mr chair i wanted
it noting for accuracy because
um there was a roll call of councillors
present and councillor flukerjoe in the
meeting i'm not sure what time i think
it was 1809
and i think that needs to be put in that
he joined the meeting because that was
the interference and the noise chairman
thank you oh good point thank you very
much uh welcome councillor fluco
good to see that you're here um
okay well apart from that i personally
feel this is reasonably uncontroversial
it's uh
the buildings are going to be tidied up
uh it looks uh
like there are no local objections so
um i'm thinking that we might go to the
votes
unless anybody else wants to speak is
there anybody else
um or would you like to uh agree by
a cent well i sent mr chairman
okay um well uh let me know if you agree
then please
green read great
all right thank you that's uh agreed and
approved
uh now on to the next item which is
item six planning application
twenty stroke zero one one four five
stroke full
land adjacent springwood directory lane
lachendon
found on pages 25-44
in a moment i'll call on the officer to
present this item members
as a reminder if you wish to speak on
this item please make this known by
using the hands up function
within this meeting i will then come to
you in turn
and please keep your points clear and
succinct
uh miss dungate um
please repl present the report
yes thank you chairman um planning
permission is sought for the
construction of five bungalows at the
application site
which fronts burnham road as shown in
red
on the attached site plan
this is the site location plan
this is the proposed block plan
two two bedroom bungalows are proposed
next to primrose house
and three three bedroom bungalows are
proposed to the west of the site
this application follows a planning
application that was refused
last year on design grounds for five
three-bedroom bungalows at the site
extant permission for four houses
already exists at the site
the proposal for four two-story houses
was allowed at appeal in 2018
and this is the proposed block plan
showing the approved scheme
these are the street elevations for the
site at the top
is the street elevation showing the four
two-story houses that have already been
granted planning permission at the site
in the middle shows the previously
refused scheme
for the five three-bedroom bungalows and
at the bottom shows the current scheme
for two two bedroom bungalows and three
three bedroom bungalows
these are the proposed elevations floor
and roof plans for the two bed bungalows
located at plots one and two
these are the proposed elevations of the
three bed bungalow located at plot three
and these are the proposed floor and
roof plans of plot three
these are the proposed elevations of
plot four
and these are the proposed roof and
floor plans of plot four
these are the proposed elevation floor
and roof plans of prop 5.
this is a view of the application site
from burnham road
north facing south
this is a view of the application site
from burnham road
east facing west and it shows the two
existing houses
at the junction of burnham road and
rectory lane
this is also a view of the application
site from burnham road
north facing south again showing the
existing development located on the
opposite side of burnham road
this is a close-up of the two existing
bungalows located opposite site
and here is another view of the
development front and burning road
opposite the site
this is the bowling center located west
of the site
and this is the view of the site which
is obscured by hedging
from rectory lane
to summarize the reduction in built form
at the site from the previously refused
scheme has meant that the proposal would
on balance
not be considered harmful to the
character of the area
in the context of the existing approved
scheme for four two-story houses at the
site
as well as the existing development
located north of burnham road
the proposal for five bungalows is
therefore considered to be
acceptable the proposal would
contribute to the identified need for
smaller houses in the area
given the reduction of two of the
bungalows to two bed properties
and taking into account the planet
permission for four four bedroom
dwellings at the site
the proposal would better the overall
supply of smaller homes in this location
thank you thank you hella we have
one public participant for this uh
planning application
uh in line with the public participation
scheme
i now invite the agent uh mr russell
ford
to read out his submission and i remind
you uh please mr ford that you are
allocated two minutes
only for public speaking in accordance
with this scheme
thank you chairman can you hear me i can
hear you i think we all can
then i'll begin uh there is ex extent
planning permission
in place for four two-story houses with
garages on this site
on reflection we felt that the
development would key better into both
local character and local need
if it consisted of smaller properties
that were single story
hence in 2020 we proposed five
single-story dwellings
comparative street elevations clearly
showed the lesser impact of the bungalow
scheme
compared with the two-story scheme the
parish council supported the proposal
it was therefore with some bewilderment
that planning permission was refused
under delegated powers
with alleged harm to rural character and
appearance
exiting latchington towards burnham have
you seen the developments in depth on
the east side of burnham road
our simple frontage screen between two
houses and the jack center
with mature roadside planting would have
had considerably less impact than this
nevertheless we came back to the table
with the officers and produced a scheme
which reduced two of the bungalows in
size
removed their attached garages and also
removed a detached double garage from
the scheme
these revisions put the matter beyond
reproach
to assist you we have produced
comparative street elevations
these showed the approach approved
two-story scheme the refused bungalow
scheme
and the current reduced bungalow scheme
the visual impact of the bungalow scheme
is considerably less
than the two-story development and would
be a better fit to local housing need
it is a genuine win-win situation the
current application is recommended for
approval
it has the support of both latchington
and old thorn parish councils
there are no third party objections
everyone agrees
and i hope that you will do too and
grant planning permission tonight thank
you
thank you very much uh mr ford and uh
uh is there anybody any other officer
that cares to comment on the scheme
before we go to the recommendation
i'll take that as a no uh the
recommendation is set out within the
report
is as follows that planning application
twenty stroke zero one one four five
stroke
full land adjacent spring wood rectory
laying lachington be
approved for the reason as detailed in
section 8 of the report
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
council hell i'll second that thank you
councillor helm
i'll now invite members to make any
comments on the report berna
has anybody yes i see several people
have
is that the way this works is that uh
council stamp
goes first is that right yes indeed and
then councillor hall council boyce yes
i've got it now okay councillor stamp
please thank you chair thank you berna
i'm really sorry i dropped out i totally
lost everything had to log on in a
separate device
so i didn't even see the whole of the
submission so i'm really apologize
to uh whoever that i cannot vote on this
thank you very much indeed uh councillor
stamp that is a pity
uh counselor hull please
your muted counselor how
sorry um just a highway is okay with
this because that bend is quite nasty
sometimes
to hannah would you like to answer that
yes of course
um highways didn't actually respond
to this application however they did
respond to
the previous application in 2020 and
also
an application in 2018 which was for
three houses at the site
and on both of those occasions they had
no objections to the
proposal subject to um conditions
relating to the site access so
that should be constructed at right
angles and with appropriate visibility
displays
and also included conditions in relation
to parking
so to ensure that the parking spaces are
retained
for car parking only as well as the
garages on site
so in terms of highways there's been no
objections
and there are several conditions um
securing the site access to be
constructed as it has been shown on the
plans
could you do this all a favor and show
the image which shows that
entrance onto that bend yep
is that the image you're after uh yes
yes i think that's so right in the
center of the image is the uh
it shows how the entrance is happening
can everybody see that
uh council is there anything else you
want to add to your comment
no no that's fine thank you um okay i'll
now move
uh if you put your hand down i'll go to
council of voice next
we can return to the general images
please uh hannah
thank you thank you chairman
um the last photograph i believe that
was shown
is rather interesting it shows a lot of
water
exactly and um
if members are aware of the recent
flooding lattingham was one of those
areas
and this area was one of those that were
flooded
now the development itself i've not got
any real problems with
but i would like to know what extra
work has been done
to try and prevent and reduce
the water from this development adding
to this
flooded area and the the development
opposite
i've objected to in the past because
of flooding but that
that got passed because it allegedly had
its own um scheme
to deal with the water
this um i would like reassurances
that there is something in effect
uh to prevent additional problems with
flooding in latchington
thank you chairman thank you councillor
boyce uh
hannah can you help us with that yes of
course um
we have a condition on the application
um requesting details for surface water
and foul water drainage
for the scheme so that would obviously
prevent or seek to prevent any excess
water
flooding into the surrounding area
environmental health have been consulted
and they don't have
any issue with the application subject
to that condition being
included which it is um i'm not sure
if we can prevent obviously flooding to
the wider area as part of this scheme
and obviously just to remind members
again that
permission has already been granted for
four houses at the site
um and the condition was included on
that previous application as well
to submit details for foul water
drainage and surface water drainage so
um in terms of this application and
unless
michael or matt have anything to add i
think that hopefully answers your
question
uh thank you hannah yes adam it occurs
to me it's uh
is at the bottom of that hill uh and uh
i don't know whether any other
councillors before the officers come
back
have any evidence from the recent heavy
rains that that particular site has been
subject to flood flooding
do any only councillors aware
and if not any other officer would care
to comment on this
there isn't um really anything much to
say uh councillor schemes i think as
hannah said it out
um there is extant planning permission
for built form of although a different
design
um of a similar type um
in terms of um
you know built area on on the land the
access point is exactly the same
this is within the same development
envelope as
previously approved for four houses so
there isn't anything material
that can be considered different to this
scheme
as to what can be built um tomorrow if
the developer
so wished thank you michael johnson
uh i saw um michael uh sorry uh mark
bassinger's hand go up
then disappeared so i'm assuming he
doesn't want to speak but uh
councillor stamp has raised her hand
cancer stamp would you like to
go ahead yeah thank you i would i think
um what
council boyce has raised is very valid
uh we all know that we've had a lot of
flooding
because we've had to uh as a district
council we've had to house people who
were flooded
um yes i totally agree with what the
officers have said that it has got the
planning permission
but we've also got a responsibility not
to add to flooding without putting in
mitigating circumstances
and i don't want to put words in cancer
boyce's mouth but i think
he he was actually alluding to that we
do have a responsibility
so if if those conditions can be
strengthened in any ways
i'd look for the officer's
recommendation or support mr lee or
whoever to actually to see if there is
anything we can actually do
because if we aren't going to make it
stronger in the future
we are going to be evacuating and moving
people from them home
their homes because of flooding thank
you
uh thank you councillor stamp um um uh
mr lee do you have anything
else to add to that um i think was done
gate covered quite well but i just will
obviously
account for that number stamp sorry
counselor stamp had a direct question so
i will come back on that
the has canceled voice indicating
relation to the application site
opposite is
necessity for an application to wash its
own face if you want to prepare a phrase
and
as decision makers we're all aware that
we're
we're not able to shoulder an existing
burden
on existing or not proposed development
this application has a condition that
require details to be submitted
and it will be a requirement through
that process to ensure that the
development of this site does not
increase flooding off of this site i'm
off off so i can't won't create any
flooding off this site through
impact so uh there'll be sustainable
drainage etc are required
so i think to be honest the cap
condition is as robust as we can have it
because it will
require details be submitted and it will
be a requirement that it doesn't create
any harm
we can't require anything above that
through a condition
or through the planning process and as
always i wouldn't encourage conditions
to get too descriptive at this stage
because
we should be leaving up to the applicant
to come up with their solution that they
see appropriate if we don't consider it
to be appropriate the discharge
condition would be refused
thank you chairman thank you very much
uh uh mr lee
um and uh councillor passenger your hand
is out
thank you mr chairman um i would just
like to say and and i can hear
um what councilor boyce is saying and
it's correct but this historically has
been an area
which is generally had flooding and
that's mainly because of the water
that's coming down
um rectory lane which is a very steep
hill
and i can't see that this development
would really add to that what
seems to have been the general consensus
at latin and parish council
is the fact that the ditches um which
should be maintained
by the people on the field whether
that's farmers whoever are not
really cleared properly and consequently
the water itself is not running away in
the way it used to
so i can only only say that you know
this isn't something new this has been
going on for years and years and
every time it rains we get flooding on
that corner
but that lane is always wet we've the
water border there
there's permanently water running down
that lane so
i can only sort of you know reiterate
that this is sort of a historical
problem and i'm not sure that
um the development would add anything to
it
in in the way of of preventing the water
and causing any more flooding thank you
thank you councillor passenger uh
councillor helm your hand is up
thank you mr chairman retro lane has
always been a problem since the wind
farm traffic use all the hgvs
and they fill the ditches in to create
past uh passing places
and they haven't been reinstated the
ditches are all full up
like everywhere in the in the district
until we get that alleviated we won't
have any we won't be able to kill the
flooding problem
thank you yes i think that's probably
going to be a matter for
highways and essex county council uh
uh councillon could you put your hand
down as well please if you'd be so kind
uh okay is there anybody else who would
like to speak on this
i'll take that as a no uh so
berna uh we can now take a vote or do
people
wish to agree by a cent i
is there anybody objecting or will uh
are we happy to agree by ascent
by our center
all right so yes let's do that do we
agree by scent
agree we agreed agree
well okay then in burner which
assume we all agree that that is
approved
and we can now move on to the next item
of business
which is any other items of business
that the chair
of the committee decides are urgent and
i have
none so therefore i thank you for your
contributions this afternoon we're
moving to
draw the meeting to close at uh
6 34 uh p.m
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion on this forum
and to please leave the meeting promptly
thank you very much indeed everybody
thank you